Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Ho trascorso gran parte dell'ultimo anno in California,
in Silicon Valley, e sono qui per condividere con voi
la mia esperienza di start-upper pugliese in Silicon Valley.
Lo voglio fare, dato che è una serata in parte dedicata al cibo,
utilizzando un linguaggio che è quello della cucina
e quindi rivisiterò il concetto di start-up,
di queste imprese innovative di cui tanto si parla,
in versione culinaria, utilizzando delle metafore
che vi spiegano alcuni semplici concetti riguardo l'impresa.
Questo talk nasce mentre preparavo dei muffin alla banana,
e mi è sembrato molto strano il fatto che un italiano,
con tutto ciò che la cultura della cucina italiana ha fatto nel mondo,
preparasse dei muffin alla banana. E così ho immaginato:
"Se un italiano può importare una ricetta americana in Italia,
perché un italiano non può esportare un modello di impresa
e in particolare di impresa innovativa, nel cuore pulsante
in cui nascono le imprese innovative, la Silicon Valley?&quot;
E quindi, in questo gioco di ruoli capovolti, mi sono immaginato
un modello di impresa, un modello di start-up
che peschi direttamente dal nostro territorio
e che possa essere esportato.
Adesso ve ne parlo in termini, appunto, di cibo.
E lo faccio per tre motivi principali:
Primo perché mangiare, fondamentalmente, risponde
a una di queste due cose o entrambe:
mangiare è una necessità, un bisogno di sostentamento per il nostro corpo,
ma mangiare è anche un piacere,
(come ci testimonia il fatto che siamo qui tutti insieme)
esattamente come creare un'impresa.
Steve Blank, che è uno dei più grandi imprenditori americani,
uno dei teorici delle imprese innovative di Stanford,
direbbe che un'impresa nasce per soddisfare un bisogno,
una necessità: quindi immaginate un'azienda
che produce carrozzine per persone tetraplegiche;
oppure per soddisfare un desiderio, uno sfizio:
immaginate un'azienda che produce macchine che vadano a 300 km/h.
Il secondo motivo per cui associo l'impresa alla cucina
è perché molto spesso tanti imprenditori molto famosi
hanno associato già il mondo del cibo al mondo dell'imprenditoria.
Ricordate la frase “Stay hungry, stay foolish”
di Steve Jobs: siate affamati, siate folli.
Nella mia esperienza americana la frase più significativa
che ho incontrato e che associa imprenditoria e cibo è questa,
di Guy Kawasaky,
che dice: “Entrepreneurs don't just like to eat, they like to bake”,
cioè agli imprenditori, agli intraprendenti, non piace solo mangiare,
a loro piace preparare, cucinare per gli altri.
Poi è chiaro che prenderanno una fetta di questa torta,
ma lo faranno quando la torta sarà diventata sufficientemente grande
da dare da mangiare a tutti, a tanti se non altro.
Il terzo motivo per cui parlo di start-up e cibo
è perché quando si parla di fare una start-up,
quando uno ha un'idea innovativa, subito gli viene detto "ma che ci fai,
che stai a fare qui in Italia, devi andare in Silicon Valley,
perché lì è il mondo delle start-up".
E questo è vero, ma fino a un certo punto:
perché non immaginare un mondo tutto italiano
in cui le start-up sono possibili?
Che c'entra questo con il cibo?
Beh, la cucina italiana ha avuto tanto da dire
e ha tuttora tanto da dire nel mondo.
Abbiamo esportato un modello di cucina italiana
e siamo riconosciuti per la cucina italiana.
Perciò, così come il nostro corpo impara a odorare dal cibo
e dal territorio in cui si trova,
perché non provare a rivisitare il modello di start-up,
che è tipicamente americano,
partendo dal territorio, partendo dai sapori locali e facendo in modo
che questi semi germoglino attraverso il talento delle persone
e diventino un modello esportabile?
La ricetta che vi propongo stasera si chiama "Start-up alla barese"
e in particolare attinge alla cucina mediterranea,
proprio perché propone un modello d'impresa che è "lean",
agile, essenziale, frugale, che è esattamente
come bisogna impostare l'impresa
affinché possa essere competitiva e innovativa.
Cosa c'è di più sperimentale che non trovarsi davanti
a degli strumenti per cucinare, a degli ingredienti?
Cos'è una ricetta, tutto sommato? Una ricetta è la formalizzazione
di un esperimento culinario, esattamente come una start-up.
Una start-up non è una versione in piccolo di una grande impresa,
come direbbe appunto Steve Blank. Una start-up è tutta un'altra cosa,
è proprio una sperimentazione, un periodo che va da tre a cinque anni,
quindi un tempo di cottura, un tempo di preparazione
che va da tre a cinque anni, in cui le persone che compongono la start-up
hanno il compito di trovare un modello che sia scalabile e ripetibile.
Che cosa intendo? Una ricetta, come ho detto,
è la formalizzazione di un modello. Una ricetta di una start-up
propone un modello che può essere implementato ovunque nel mondo,
più o meno allo stesso modo, quindi è ripetibile,
può essere ripetuto in Italia come in Francia,
come in Silicon Valley. Ed è scalabile,
ovvero se voglio passare da un piatto per quattro persone
a un piatto per quattro milioni di persone
non devo cambiare le regole della preparazione, devo solo cambiare le dosi
e questa è la quintessenza della ricetta
e riflette la quintessenza di una start-up.
Passiamo agli ingredienti. Io vi parlerò soltanto degli ingredienti,
poi ovviamente si tratta di una sperimentazione, perciò lascerò a voi
provare a creare la vostra impresa, la vostra start-up.
Il primo ingrediente è l'idea.
Esattamente come quando iniziamo a immaginare una ricetta,
io l'idea l'ho rappresentata come la pasta, proprio perché quando iniziamo
a immaginare la ricetta possiamo utilizzare tantissimi tipi di pasta,
ma noi abbiamo un'idea precisa in mente, sappiamo esattamente
che cosa vogliamo cucinare,
sappiamo esattamente quello che vogliamo mangiare.
Una start-up nasce con un'idea, che come ho detto prima
risponde a un bisogno o a un desiderio. Quest'idea è una,
e questo rappresenta il fatto
che una start-up deve essere “focused” su un concetto,
per cui se vogliamo preparare le orecchiette con le cime di rapa
c'è un solo tipo di pasta, ed è quello che funziona.
La seconda componente di una start-up è il team.
Per una buona start-up servono da tre a cinque cime.
Che cosa intendo? Che le persone che compongono una start-up
devono essere il meglio del meglio,
ma soprattutto devono essere coese e motivate.
Uno dei maggiori motivi di fallimento di una start-up
è proprio il fatto che il team possa collassare per i motivi più disparati.
Per questo in una start-up noi vogliamo esattamente delle cime.
Il terzo ingrediente della nostra ricetta
per una start-up innovativa sono le risorse.
Ne servirà giusto un pugno.
Questo perché, come le idee migliori
in Silicon Valley sono partite in un garage,
le idee migliori non hanno bisogno di enormi risorse,
ma giusto dell'essenziale affinché possano essere realizzate.
Quindi servirà la tecnologia, serviranno
le strutture, serviranno le risorse umane,
serviranno anche i fondi per portare avanti un'idea,
però dovranno essere centellinati, utilizzati in maniera frugale.
Questo perché un sovradosaggio di risorse
rispetto alla pasta, o al team, quindi all'idea,
oppure ai componenti, non permetteranno di gestire le risorse stesse,
non permetteranno di realizzare un piatto saporito come dovrebbe essere.
Il quarto ingrediente sono i partner.
Ne serve giusto un pizzico, proprio perché
devono essere veramente selezionati, ma soprattutto devono intervenire
quando ormai la fame ve la siete tolta,
perché quando siete veramente affamati
voi non state a pensare se la bistecca è sufficientemente salata,
ma è proprio quando iniziate ad assaporare
il sapore più delicato della carne, allora lì dite:"Beh,
adesso un po' di sale non ci starebbe per niente male".
I partner sono quelli che vi aiutano a realizzare le attività,
che vi permettono di creare la vostra impresa
utilizzando le risorse che avete a disposizione, voi o i vostri partner.
Il quinto ingrediente sono gli investimenti, che io ho rappresentato
con l'acqua, perché fondamentalmente una start-up,
così come una ricetta, è un'equazione.
Voi avete la vostra pasta, la vostra idea, che dovrete necessariamente
mettere in un contenitore pieno d'acqua, quindi ci vorranno delle risorse
per far maturare la vostra idea, per far cuocere la pasta.
Però questa pasta può cuocere soltanto se c'è il fuoco
che identifica sostanzialmente quante risorse bruciate
per ogni unità di tempo, cioè quanto denaro impiegate,
quanti soldi impiegate per realizzare la vostra ricetta.
Ora gli investimenti, così come l'acqua in una ricetta,
devono essere il giusto.
Troppi investimenti, un sistema magari come quello americano,
che per certi versi è un po' dopato in termini di investimenti,
diluisce molto la vostra ricetta
e alla fine il sapore ne risulta compromesso
e soprattutto la pasta risulta scotta.
Non so se avete mai mangiato pasta all'estero, però ve ne potete accorgere.
La ricetta si compone di questi cinque elementi e ovviamente,
indipendentemente dall'idea alla base di questa ricetta,
componendo team, idea, risorse, investimenti e partner,
ognuno con un'idea innovativa,
si può realizzare una start-up secondo alcuni criteri.
Io non vi parlerò adesso della preparazione di una start-up
perché è un percorso indipendente che non si può insegnare,
vi darò giusto alcuni spunti che ho raccolto
negli ultimi mesi, nell'ultimo anno,
sia in California che nell'attività che sto realizzando.
Il primo è “Be bold with care”,
cioè siate spregiudicati ma fatelo con cura.
Un intraprendente, di fatto, sfida le convenzioni.
C'è un passaggio molto bello di un libro
che si chiama "Il Principe" di Nicolò Machiavelli,
che dice che non c'è niente di più difficile da attuare che l'innovazione,
perché cambia totalmente delle convenzioni e quindi, per farlo,
bisogna essere sufficientemente coraggiosi, avendo cura però delle persone.
Proprio per questo, un modello di start-up che nasce in un territorio,
e che è ispirato ad una ricetta mediterranea, non può avere il profitto,
quindi il capitale, come unico risultato, ma anche proprio la redistribuzione.
Un altro aspetto dell'essere spregiudicati
è il fatto di essere “disruptive”.
Il “disruptive thinking” è quello che vi permette
di generare idee rivoluzionarie,
però l'introduzione di idee rivoluzionarie
richiede una preparazione dei vostri interlocutori.
Le menti più brillanti, che hanno generato idee straordinarie, molto spesso
non sono state comprese nel loro tempo,
proprio perché gli uomini del loro tempo non erano in grado
di recepire l'innovazione. Quindi dovete fare “framing”,
cioè comunicare nella maniera opportuna quello che state facendo,
filtrare la vostra innovazione, le vostre idee brillanti,
lasciare che sedimentino nella mente delle persone.
Il terzo spunto è “Exploit the right tools”,
ovvero sfruttate gli strumenti che avete a disposizione.
Una ricetta si compone di ingredienti, sì, ma anche di strumenti.
Noi italiani abbiamo una risorsa fondamentale, che sono le circostanze
e, soprattutto in questo momento storico, noi pugliesi
abbiamo veramente la capacità di giocare un ruolo
nel mondo dell'innovazione.
In questo momento ci sono veramente le circostanze:
il periodo economico turbolento, una voglia di attivazione, una rabbia,
l'impossibilità di trovare un posto fisso, che creano le condizioni
e l'humus necessari a sviluppare innovazione.
Quindi se c'è un momento per fare start-up è esattamente questo,
e se c'è un posto dove si può fare innovazione, start-up
è esattamente la Puglia o il Mediterraneo in generale.
In particolare ci tengo a dire che noi italiani siamo visti,
appunto, come i bamboccioni, trentenni bamboccioni;
il fatto di riuscire a rimanere a casa ma di fare esperienza all'estero,
ci permette di mantenere gli asset,
le spese basse e di investire nel nostro futuro.
Una delle regole delle start-up è proprio quella di
non investire in risorse non necessarie,
di essere agili, di essere essenziali, frugali nell'uso delle risorse.
Il quinto spunto è “Give something back”.
Una start-up non è profitto, un'impresa non è necessariamente profitto.
Noi siamo abituati ad un modello imprenditoriale che è stato costituito
sulla base di anni in cui l'immaginario è stato vilipeso
da modelli imprenditoriali di arraffoni sostanzialmente.
L'idea, e il momento,
richiedono di implementare un modello che sia differente,
che non guardi solo al profitto
ma anche al beneficio sociale dell'imprenditoria,
che guardi appunto al territorio
perché lì, come ho detto, nascono le idee.
L'ultimo spunto è “Do your next big thing“.
Non pensate che una start-up sia il lavoro della vostra vita:
così come non è possibile trovare un posto fisso,
non è possibile crearsi un posto fisso con una start-up.
Una start-up, così come una ricetta, nasce per essere un'esperienza.
Nasce per essere consumata, nasce per essere metabolizzata,
e già in sé gli ingredienti hanno in qualche modo la morte,
il riciclo.
E così come una ricetta nasce per creare valore, essere consumata,
assimilata, essere apprezzata, una start-up nasce per morire,
e non è l'idea di un'azienda che rimarrà per sempre.
Perciò, fatta una start-up, pensate già a quella successiva,
e questo è il senso del “Do your next big thing”.
E con questo ho finito il mio breve quadro sulle start-up,
perciò non mi resta che augurarvi buon appetito.
(Applausi)